negli episodi precedenti di residenti
volo nostro non stop con l'ultimo
proiettile da cecchino è una borsa il
casco male bravissima ma se non voglio
questo non voglio perché neanche il
ballottaggio si salva ragazzi se non ci
troppo contento di links di riutilizzare
crisi dopo un sacco di tempo su su
residenti vol
a questo è il villaggio madonna cosa è
successo qua a noi la fabbrica esplosa
quella a minchia c'è un po di scena
politi in tavolini sul castello non ero
mica visti armi biologiche a parte
quindi ethan è veramente morto un gruppo
di una storica [ __ ] mica quanto è
forte il suo fucile o no ma ragazzi fi
pazzesco fucile pazzesco è fortissimo
allora mi date copertura dall'alto voi
della lp aic a swat stars loro dette
tutte avere un lavoro azzeccata non lo
avrò azzeccata sicuro non sto sprecando
troppi corvi perché non solo può quanti
me ne serviranno giacche sono reduce dal
fatto che con i tagli o finiti tutti e
sono sopravvissuto per miracolo quindi
un purissimo non sottovalutarli be nice
addirittura granata è fantastico o che è
successo c'è qualcuno di grosso
via via via via via via via madonna che
casino quale a fare
deve essere vivo a questo tocca questo
affare o non avevo capito bene ed è
effettivamente tanto fastidio mg giorno
cosa faccio non è vero mai
e c'è un po ci sono poi problemi ragazzi
che queste cose che non li faccio morire
dice al telefono è andato madonna che
non posso ammirare col mirino sarebbe
finissimo provate ma è morto è morto è
morto adesso è morto è morto per le
scuole sco ko by cris lei scampate tutte
residenti non ce la farei anche adesso
posso usare anche le altre armi perché
presto stavano solo questa
usiamo questa perché è troppo forte raga
mi sbatto cv cristo ricevuto ma il fuoco
io me ne vado quando ce li proietti
lizzy madonna quanto europa e bellissimo
trovare i giusti proiettili mamma mia oh
era ecco mi sono pagato in mano ed era
semplicemente il il coso visore notturno
andate a cagare
beh avessi avuto equipaggiamento con
ethan sai dove sarei arrivato a
quest'ora avrei finito gioco otto volte
nice nice
bellissimo questo fucile troppo figo ko
minchia quello grosso guarda poi muoiono
che soddisfazione raga e bellissimo
draga quello grosso da buttar giù e non
casi poi mi sa guidare la bomba non l'ho
tirata ma vabbè era meglio se tira con
la bomba qua adesso abbiamo fatto col
fucile ma arcore quella bomba era
necessaria e ragazzi sicuro
[Applauso]
ok li ho fatti fuori tutti e male e non
hanno tutti noi qua ra qua andava usata
la bomba ragazze la prossima volta
utilizzerò quella per adesso ok ma
quanta gente che casino
nemmeno mai mi sono usciti con chris e
non contano solo quest ora sai che mi
ero mosso
ok vabbè ragazze troppo troppo casino un
po troppo cattivo ok ok basta basta
gente basta gente un casino ma sta gente
una destinazione me ne ero accorto anche
dalla distanza che l'hanno ricevuto
giocato per marcare il bersaglio
distrugge
ok perché devo fa ci fu le cerca un
minuto e sto fermo o mio dio
very nice ma perché non lo vedevi senza
laser scusa c'era bisogno il laser per
vederlo lo faccio fuori così segno un
punto con il marcatore lanciato da mao è
aperto mi sa che tra un po mi devo
curare ma tra un po subito tanto c'è
mica non c'è mica bordello anzi certo è
comodo
madonna tutte le fila tutte tutte tutte
motivate di per leo tirate tutte porca
[ __ ] e sono ancora vivi tutti
dovevi rimini sempre lì non puoi sparare
da solo e sempre riposto nei che è
cambiato divisione care di scavalcare
aziende rischia valcar e 6 dell fbi
della cia tutti insieme sei e non sei
scavalcare il recinto alla olio cuore
santo iddio ok no devi fare veloce
veloce giro veloce siamo docenti non
docenti voce di un obiettivo veloce
azione dello zio l'ho fatta non so come
ma ce l'ho fatta
sono morti tutti in ios e si sente ad
essere bisogno nonché non so come ho
fatto la gara erano veramente troppi
madonna che battaglia incredibile
incredibile
sono troppo contento di aver finito
sì sì con katz era per dire che adesso
arriva il bello però vabbè mi piaceva un
modo per scendere
io vado a 18 proprio ecco ultimi c'è un
po di roba meno male da chi vince segno
delle alterazioni che genoma presenti
nella serie a ha visto meno male che è
nata qua e speriamo che muoia qua al
fatto e quello mi butto 18 a prescindere
a me tutto l'anno
insomma quello che ruggisce non capisco
chi eccolo oggi un altro col martello
nuovo
il sogno di supporto ai fatti come farai
nato usa quella sì sì vengo duro
tranquillo ci penso io ci penso io mica
mi ammazza
come faccio a tenere duro questo è
gigantesco
darlo sanno che inseriva bile questo
posto è ancora non posso colpire un polo
possa colpire un polo possa colpire
nicchia
si sono accorti che non posso schifare
pd tanto poi un metro quadro vero
meno male che lo faccio
eccola
mori sono qui su porca [ __ ]
come faccio ammirarlo senza devo
muovermi grandissimo minchia meno male
meno male e non è morto è morto ma cosa
porta ma come se non vuole così ciao è
finita se non muore così è finita
ragazzi l'ho presa in faccia non fa
niente tranquilli e succede tutti i
giorni a chris redfield tranquilli
ricarica lo zio nel frattempo non so
come sopravvivere ma con un altro
dettaglio va bene ci si aspettiamo
ancora un po dai che mi sto divertendo
mica pagano le aziende dai mancato la
mancato veloce
e morto no rimaniamo così dai tanto mi
sto divertendo
adesso è diventato pieno di melma e non
so se è una buona notizia però vabbè non
gli sparano anche più attive a una morte
morte molto che è piovuto e morto da
solo per fare gol
mazza chiodata cristallizzata da guarda
più in superficie
non è che mi senta tanto al sicuro
adesso vendola possono anche più vendere
non sono anche più ethan posso comprare
lo va dal duca qua non c'è pillole non
c'è più gli oggetti ai tesori sì però
vabbè madonna raga che cazzo di eg era
riuscito a lanciarlo lei dove
l'immaginario che se sia liberata di lei
e infatti i miei morti a scure come
faceva miranda sapere di rose e la
protezione cellino del sito che io sto
pensiero non celino amo fitto degli
centrate vi sul fianco
ma la domanda è secondo me mia è sempre
stata miranda
a quel punto c'è dal 7 in poi
no che cacchio estero ad altra squadra
non localizzato il nega vicente vettori
fili a questo casino e se non aspettavo
altro
il prof secondo me non serve un cambio
questa cosa però provaci insufficiente
per distruggere il villaggio prima
eliminiamo miranda è faccia fate che
pare tutti insieme no non potete far
saltare tutto prima e poi dopo eliminare
milan da fate prima
mantenetevi a distanza non muovetevi
devo farla forio con chris ragazzi omero
io mi ero portato ragazzi hanno portato
la magnum io perché volevo fare boss
finale con la magnum non sono riuscito
se non si aspettava che di perché è
morto vita attraverso avrebbe dovuto
dirglielo
dov'è che siamo come torno a casa deve
essere il laboratorio di quanta roba che
figo ok e nei laboratori di miranda non
ci sono mica proiettili per me è vero
sarebbe interessante vabbè chissenefrega
andiamo a trovare la zia vai colpisci il
lucchetto insieme un po eccessivo ko ma
non è così san rocco
eccola lì la mia mahoney bene in vista
mirri dove si trova a mirandola a monet
non è mia e miranda sicuro no cazzo
hanno allora ecco che ami ami davvero tu
non mi credete quando di quelle volta
per fortuna stai bene mi sa che ci fai
qui
mi hanno preso e mi hanno analizzato gli
ho detto mira proprio lei glielo dici tu
che lei è morto il marito
il film la figlia non puoi lasciarmi qui
aveva fatto una promessa
hai detto che ci avresti e protetti non
è la davano vero quello che volevi ci
siamo persino trasferiti qui ea me
andava bene purché rimanessimo insieme
quindi ora dimmi dove mio marito che è
di mia figlia di iera un po chris di chi
non può scusa con lui ho fallito però
posso salvare russo vabbè bella notizia
è mia
pensa che ci avevo per la magnum ma ha
fatto fuori miranda questo posto non è
sicuro in che senso hai fallito è che
senza è morto ecco gli ha detto mi
spiace ma dobbiamo andare voli spara gli
spara mi sa che il villaggio 9 ti sbagli
ho provato a tenerlo nascosto ma cosa
tu non puoi capire quanto lui sia
speciale chi vita cosa cosa non capisco
lui chi aiuta sono vivo con il cuore ma
viva sì certo va beh ma si va bene tanto
non non avevo le dita non avevo le
braccine avevo il cervello non avevo il
cuore ma tanto hai perso il cuore ma sei
vivo tranquillo succede ogni tanto
capita qualcuno tesi ma veramente radici
questo non crepa manco a pagarlo ma qui
dove sono cioè non sono via del fosso di
prima che regga cosa sta succedendo e
non sto capendo mi sto trasformando così
grazie tanto che ci fai
ma è la più bella notizia di oggi tra
cioè miranda no devo ancora salvare rosa
miranda
tu sei morto da te ne stai dicendo o
soccor amore
adesso mi risveglio incazzato come una
bestia sicuro mi fa diventare un mostro
roba ma infatti l'ho sempre detto
dall'inizio che lo dico che c'è un mese
mi ha attaccato 20 braccia sono a posto
questa residenti con sette ragazzi i
pugnali che mi ero preso in faccia
questo anche sul campo
ed è proprio lui mi avevano ammazzato
già si è quindi impossibile non ci credo
beh effettivamente avrebbe senso visto
che ti sei preso tante di quelle
martellate appunto confondermi passata
no davvero schifo stare insieme
cosa che cosa sono ora
[Musica]
lo stesso descrive pharma ed è mia
ci siamo raga è il momento
nel momento in cui bello quello che
pensa che io sia mia madre dopo tre
giorni che non mi lavo famiglia
ma quindi c'è rosa è nata da me centro
rosa è nata da ethan che è ricoperta di
muffa e quindi vai migliore possibile
e nata da un corpo morto e quindi quindi
sono dove suono cosa succede sono nella
chiesetta sono a chi lo ha riconosciuto
che ho finalmente no non è la cosa che
mi ha tenuto alimenta sulla mia carrozza
sta vivendo
agli inizi di skyrim ducati il dubbio è
vero che è stata fenomenale grazie caro
apparsa miranda in persona e mi ha
strappato il quale vista da conta è che
sono svenuto non manca molto all'alba
gioca mister di un favore portami da
miranda mi aspettavo lo chiedessi e
siamo già in viaggio ma quindi scusa io
sono senza il cuore quello che succede a
grazie se non posso morire maitan ne sei
proprio certo il tuo corpo
cade a pezzi
sì che domanda sciocca meno ma le ragala
magnum e mi serve meno male cosa sei tu
e questo vorrei sapere per me è arduo
risponderle nota mango lui siamo giunti
qui non sa che cos'è
lui non sa è un sono piante premo che
non potrai più fare ritorno alla vita di
prima
tranquillo sei pronto perché no ad e
volevo comprare le ultime cose da lei
prima mi faccia comprare delle robe
aspetta con completi della roba prima ho
sentite qua mi piegai storia la mia
magnews è very nice
very nice fammi comprende la roba almeno
prima perché devo rimettermi un attimo
action a tua ultima occasione grazie
allora borsello del duca ciò la mazza
chiodata cristalizzata il di cris
ce l'ho io va bene ai sembra coltissimo
riguarda sigaro cubano
ok mi sono fatto 200k adesso ok on bike
perfetto e devo potenziarli
assolutamente la magnum magnum massima
provino non è massima non è neanche
massima e livello se non sono denaro di
sposarsi ma costa ancora di più ma don
allora è invece mentiamo quella del coso
qua ok non ho massimo nel cecchino nella
magnum però sono tutti e due molto molto
vicini al massimo ok normale sei colpi
di magnum raga sei colpi di magnum
potenziata quasi al massimo e una
potenza incredibile l'altro non corro
questa è la mia massima velocità posso
solo camminare
va bene o tutto ragazzi e tutto si va
si va che tanto io sono fatto di muffa
che m3 che me frega ha visto casinò che
me frega chiuso la pistolina cosa mi
scaldo la pistola in casa di padova
penso che sia la boss fight finale
contro miranda ma crisi in tutto questo
genere a lui proprio lui anche potevate
anche a lasciarla a casa adesso gioco vi
sono controlli lui la prossima volta i
colpi della magnum
ci manca solo quello grazie a termine
sono stronzetti nowa giusto per farsi
pagare il biglietto
non prendo più niente dato credo che sia
l'ultima cosa che devo fare l'ultima
battaglia tra virgolette quindi non
credo mi serva prendere soldi o robert
bravo ficcati in mezzo
ecco la mia splendida figlia tornata me
ma lei lo sapeva che io ero così però
quanto dimostra lo sapeva penso di no
quanto mi sei mancata quella e rosa
credo che cosa
i poteri mi abbandonano la marcia da
sola ecco ciao non t'aspettavi vero ciao
la mia comparsa con l'interessante il
tuo corpo è davvero anomalo il 2 invece
a posto restituiscimi rossa o adesso
vedrai quando ti avrò finalmente oggi
prendi la farà ma chi è chiara chris
bravo a [ __ ] crisi l'altro colpo
mentre un eternità preparando questo
momento è adesso non puoi distruggere
così
nella pa donna cercava il morto bucata
riguarda noi siamo dei rosa bazzi
[Musica]
raga eccoci chris un altro colpi non
sarebbe male ti sei sbarazzato non so
come si cosa faccio è stato insegnato
non so veramente come farla fuori da
quel punto debole il despar e basta che
ci penserò io e renderla davvero le
storie basta perché non so quale sia il
punto debole
saluti maglia porca [ __ ] sa bene cosa
si nasconde proprio allora usiamo stata
ne va bene cazzo non puoi capire che
rose via figlia alla porta [ __ ] penale
ragalata strada non ho capito quant'è
cure o me non credo di averne tantissime
dai
ecco sto provando prima utilizzare tutti
i gol di sneijder poi perché sicuramente
un'altra fase la futuro sicuro a
un'altra fase dove sei e le ha sparato
prima dove che già era prima ma davo in
aiuto scusatevi ragazzi se mi ha
staccato il cuore e non sono morto
trovato di ricordi per terra
se mi ha staccato il cuore e non sono
morto in questo caso sono state uccise
il milan va bene videogioco io muoio
perché sono sarebbe facilissimo però
nella a livello di trama non potrebbero
ucciderli o sbaglio
colpita forse l'unico modo perfetto
l'unico modo per deviare quest'attacco
secondo me e colpirla non ho più una
vita non posso di recuperare vita non
posso crearmi neanche flaconi sono morto
non faccio crearmi niente se mi colpisce
più di una volta sono finito il suo
gioco
non la vedo neanche più
sono morti un ricorso non poteva non
posso dichiararmi niente io non posso
fidarmi nulla non mi può colpire più di
un tot perché schianto
allora proprio subito che colpire la
magnum il sisma ci sono mancata
solamente senso si è risvegliato il
glorioso nei campi ok
suvvia non preoccuparti per la piccola
morta così porta ma ci pensero è forte
ma non è da si può accettare un boss di
boss finale
gates sa bene cos'è l'amore per lascerò
scappare perché vuoi di mattei che cazzo
non puoi capire che cosa mia figlia
ragazzi un po di volte la col fisco ma
non sono in grado di uccidere alla
maglia fa pensare
vabbè sono andato oltre al tutto di
prima quello sicuro
non ci dà da fare concitato mi piace di
convertire un colpo critico di pensare
che sia morto e successo tutto pepe nero
che successo che cazzo ridi comunque
colpire la maglia non l'hanno fatto
lasciamo un riposo tornerà in azione
ecco il cazzo lo dico io io non ho le
cure per questa battaglia sono morto
la donna ragazzi perché hai così bisogno
di non essersi affatto stai
perché mia figlia ma lei e sta simpatica
in questo momento del sole parola
davvero maledetta psicopatica hector e
riesce a dirle nice
questo non l'ho colpita non so perché
cucina comp ragazzi
che è successo lerda aveva appena
iniziato sarà la doppietta
o colpita si sta facendo maria ok lo
servita perfetto cambiare ma perché sto
morendo sono una pistola sola pistola
si vabbè con la pistola basta ma cosa
con la pistola ridicolo
ma cosa fa schifo ma non ci crea con la
gestione di merda ma dai ma veramente
ridicola societario ti sei sbagliata
però vabbè economia nel senso non mia
moglie mia figlia
va bene con la piccolina di merda ok o
che figo il cielo azzurro questo gioco
però non era neanche più uno abituato a
vederlo minchia sono fatta rom che vedo
è salvata anche vestitino no io sono
muffa sto scomparendo tranquilla rose a
papà cadono le braccia ma succede è
successo già in poi rivolte dovrebbe
metterci tutto a posto mi sono
disattivato tipo un robot grazie
all'aiuto chris ricchia meno male che
c'è lì forse ogni tanto ci sono ragazzi
ce l'hai fatta e finita
no stai godendo una bomba n 218 non so
se avete visto abbiamo posto
quindi ragazze non ho capito adesso sta
per esplodere
ma cos'è sta roba
porca [ __ ] c'è questa roba da quella
roba che tentava di far esplodere cris
capita però io l'avevo capito è salita
tra ormai c'è una bomba lì dentro che
raderà al suolo un intero villaggio me
ne sono accorto perché noi messa mentre
giocava con sociale matera non possiamo
essere qui
vuoi queste questa acqua e tanaro di
intelligente bravo crimine ti sta
aspettando lei e piva capisci si è mai
capito che mi sia sentito lamon traccio
a caso non so se sono proprio essere
umano non sa senza di voi piace occupati
di rossi dai cia per bambini e 9 via
[Musica]
minuti rai di persona stesse coraggio un
ultimo sforzo sempre senza le dita ogni
somma ricresciute quel il cuore sì ma la
vita
dai crisi
che è strano ma stordendo gross meriti
più di tanto
è un feto gigante sembra con la bomba
piazzata lì
la mia ma l'ho perso a devo andar lì io
proprio no pensavo di dovermi far
esplodere
ah sì
faccio io posso dire a cliccare la porta
con sé vista no minchia era proprio se
quelle cose satisfying che vedi che è
stata tutta in aria nei giochi horror
tipo che quindi tutto tutto il male
viene radiato e niente non mi hanno
fatto vedere
cioè io mi ricordo che i finali di
residenti vol c'è mi ricordo in genere
esplode tutto il posto è del tutto
satisfying perché non c'è il doppiaggio
qua qualcosa non è partito il doppiaggio
vabbè se ne frega lo faccio io faccio io
lui non ci sarebbe mai abbandonato
ora dimmi che è successo dove eccolo è
questo dicevo eccolo qua bello
satisfying chiude tutto con la merda di
tentacoli bravo tutto tutto è distrutto
o cosi cosi stato ti avevo detto di
sederti no no lui dov'è crisi cosa gli
hai fatto è morto
ci ho provato è rimasto lì per aiutarci
a fuggire
mi dispiace
capitano venga qui a vedere mi parla un
po così fuori campo la bsa non ha
mandato soldati è un'arma biologica cosa
pensavano di fare porca vacca che schifo
ci sono ordini recupera la squadra si va
alla base bsa in europa questa residenti
con 9 reti
la pagheranno cara questa troppa enfasi
data cioè se c'è un po di meno
la bambina la solfa
ma questo non siamo un po troppo il
castello è rimasto che bello è stato è
stato veramente figo
il castello è rimasto in piedi il
castello è rimasto in piedi nonostante
il casino che ha steso è rimasto era
abbastanza vicino al villaggio nell'area
scontato o la storiella nell'inizio
titoli ricorda vediamo
proponga esclamò è stato proprio figo è
stato proprio figo allora mi posso dir
la verità mi è piaciuto più questo del 7
perché le dinamiche erano diverse c'è il
fatto che tu puoi acquistare le armi le
munizioni delle armi ste cose qua questa
questa dinamica mi piace molto di più di
residenti vaud e quello tipo di recenti
col 14 al mercante
mi piace proprio tanto sta dinamica
voglio solo aspettare la fine dei titoli
di coda per vedere se c'è qualcosa come
sempre perché alla fine mi scopro sempre
che c'è qualche cosa che non avevo visto
e quindi meglio scoprirlo adesso che è
che poi su youtube
guardando e dicendo cacchio è arrivato
alla fine potrà aspettare ancora un
posto
ecco infatti lo sapevo lo sapevo lo
sapevo
lei letto la storia sul sull'elicottero
sull'aereo quello che l'anello che è
eros da grandi ben riuscirà a toccare la
luna non chi cacchio a speculare è
troppo lontana nemmeno con un razzo
spaziale in quel caso sì ma sarebbe
molto molto fredda
ma che sciocca che sei
non penso che la luna
l'antico è mio
con le converse addirittura ci credono
più al cimitero a portare i fiori aiuta
salvio so che era già morto da tre anni
ma per sta cosa c'è scritto sulla data
di morte se la data giusta quella di tre
anni prima vediamo i papà buon
compleanno in da svelerò invader e non
mettono la data di morte
voglio vedere quando avevamo visto la
morbido la settimana scorsa ho molti
test da fare lo sai è così mi chiama
attimo e cracchi quando parli del
diavolo ecco appunto
devo andare
ti voglio bene
sì l'ho trovata
dove sono soprattutto oggi abbiamo un
problema ci servi evelyn non ti
azzardare a chiamarmi così e era solo
una battuta rosa so fare cosi ti nemmeno
crissa è in grado di immaginare a
madonna per 6 a 0 sta fermo a tutto che
le volevano pure sparare addirittura una
ragazza complimenti per la calma
gli somigli molto suoi no più o meno non
si vede spesso in faccia ethan peron
hansen si vede prossimo
quindi ethan era più o meno così ok
perché non si vede mai quindi boh che
bello comunque mamma mia mi mi stupisce
il fatto che siano passati un sacco di
anni tantissimi e comunque il mondo è
ancora in piedi quindi non è successo
niente in questi boh non so quanti anni
ora 16 cioè non ha idea quindi passati
questi 15 16 anni comunque solido e
rimuovere non so non ne annunciano
nessuna personali per ora fermo la
storia del padre è giunta al termine
o è finita la saga di the winter's
quindi avanti a tempo di completare ci
ho messo sette ore e 36 minuti un po fa
modello che bello ragazzi è stato
fighissimo slogato un sacco di roba
signori questo era l'ultimo episodio di
residenti volpi legge quindi niente come
vi ho detto prima spero che la serie vi
sia piaciuta iscrivetevi al canale
lasciate un commento qua sotto e ci
vediamo come sempre al prossimo video
ragazzi
[Musica]